بعد اذنك انا كنت اشرت قبل قليل
ل الحرج الذي وجدت فيه
نفسها المتحدثه باسم البنتاجون مع فادي
منصور لنتابع
انا فقط اخبركم انه بحسب تقديرات
الاستخبارات الامريكيه بشان ما يحدث في
غزه وكيف تستخدم حماس هذه المستشفيات
لصالحها اذا اعتبر ان هذا التقييم
الاستخبارات ق تم جمعه والتوصل اليه
استنادا الى المعلومات التي قدمتها
اسرائيل بناء على عملنا
الاستخباراتي اذا هل لديكم اي موارد على
الارض في غزه ليس لدينا عناصر على الارض
في
غزه اذا ليس هناك جمع للمعلومات على الارض
حول هذه
الامور ليس لدينا عناصر على الارض في
غزه لذا السؤال هو كيف هو هذا التقييم
اعني كيف توصلتم لخلاصه هذا
التقييم حسنا لن اخو في مزيد من التفاصيل
حول الكيفيه التي يتم بها جمع معلوماتنا
الاستخباراتيه اذا ليس لديكم مصادر على
الارض وليس عندكم احد ليدخل المستشفى ساكر
ما قلته ليس لدينا عناصر على الارض في غزه
حسنا لكن درجه الثقه التي يتم ذكرها عاده
عند مشاركه الاستخبارات لمعلوماتها او رفع
السريه عنها انت من يخبرنا عنها انا فقط
اخبركم بما تمكنت الاستخبارات من رفع
السريه عنه اليوم وكيف اعني حقيقه انني
اقراها لكم ما يعني اننا نشعر بثقه كبيره
في
مصادرنا اذا لديك مستوى ع من الثقه فقط
لانك تقولين ن وافقه من قراته لكم من على
هذه المنصه وفي تقييمنا لهذا
اليوم